هناك المساطر وخزان الصدى
والكتاب الإلكتروني
[الموسيقى]
وهي آلة عادية تعزف
عليها وتتوقع أن يكون لها صوت
ممتع ولكن مع آلة
مثل هذه الهدف هو إنتاج
الأصوات الموجودة في هذا  حالة مزعجة للغاية
[موسيقى]
كان محرك التخوف
أداة تخلق مجموعة متنوعة من
المخيف حقًا ويقول أحدهم إن الأصوات المرعبة
اسمي مارك كورفين ، أنا مؤلف موسيقى فيلم
ومؤخراً كنت أركز
على مقطوعات أفلام الرعب  أكبر
نجاحات فيما يتعلق بأفلام الرعب
كانت من أواخر التسعينيات فيلمًا
يسمى Cube ومؤخراً
قمت بتكليفه أصلاً
بالتخوف الآسيوي لأنني كنت متعبًا
ونفس العينات الرقمية التي
نتج عنها الكثير من التشابه في الكثير
من  موسيقى الرعب لذلك كنت أبحث عن
شيء تجريبي أكثر
صوتيًا من شأنه أن يمنحني
صوتًا أصليًا أكثر قليلاً حيث
اتصلت بصديقي توني دوجان سميث ، لذلك
اتصل بي مارك وسألني  لإنشاء
آلة مجنونة لأفلام الرعب
لأنني لم أفعل أي شيء من هذا القبيل
قبل أن تفرغ جيبي وجميع
الأدراج الخاصة بي من أي ثقوب
وأجزاء وأجزاء يمكن أن أقوم بربطها
معًا لتحقيق ذلك وهذا
هو ما  الكاميرا
[الموسيقى]
تفعل تلك الأشياء التي تثير
المشاعر والمشاعر الإجرامية وهناك
بالفعل مجموعة من المهارات التي يجب عليك
اكتسابها من أجل تحقيق أقصى استفادة
منها تعبر عما لا يمكن التعبير عنه حقًا
بأي طريقة أخرى  إنها ليست موسيقى
بالمعنى التقليدي على الإطلاق ، لكن اسمحوا
لي أن أصفها بهذه الطريقة ، فإن
محرك التوقيف يثير بالتأكيد عاطفة ، لذا أود
أن أسميها سهلة